this does not seem festive enough for
how festive this video is about to be
that wasn't jingle bell so was my dog
they're so much more festive
I don't like holiday music yeah I know I
just made a very polarizing statement
Polar Santa geography
I don't like holiday music it feels a
little forced it feels a little
insincere and it feels a little playing
are just a bunch of butthole singing
I've never liked holiday music as child
didn't give a [ __ ] about it i listened
to alvin and the chipmunks and then when
i went to college didn't realize that i
could speed up my own voice and make it
sound like that all the fantasy was lost
i think i might have been more affected
by knowing that i could speed up my own
voice and sound like a chipmunk then i
was by finding out that Santa Claus
isn't real
I hope so I'm going to talk to you that
but you should know that because you're
clearly already using the internet to
watch this video so that's a very I
don't hold myself responsible at all and
as an adult
analyzing Christmas and holiday songs
has made them even more awful to me so I
wanted to share that holiday cheer with
you I went on my Facebook page that's
right and I'm back on Facebook
facebook.com slash grace Helbig and I
asked you guys for your favorite holiday
songs so I could analyze them for you
and potentially ruin what great
relationship you have
it's that musical piece let's do this
baby it's cold outside
this song is about a drunk dude trying
to get a drunk girl to stay in this
house with them so you can just stuff
that stocking I look at the lyrics on
the website so sorry if they're a little
off but I'm pretty sure they're close
enough so really I'd better scurry
beautiful please don't hurry maybe just
a half a drink more put some records on
while I pour the neighbors might think
baby it's bad out there say what's in
this drink no cabs to be had out there
that girl needs a buddy system
Santa baby Santa baby just slip a sable
under the tree for me is that a car been
an awful good girl santa baby so hurry
down the chimney tonight santa baby a 54
convertible two light blue I'll wait up
for you dear santa baby so hurry down
the chimney tonight so santa memory
seems to be the anthem of a girl
obsessed with a male cougar type and she
wants a car real bad and she's desperate
hurry down the chimney tonight if I was
that desperate I feel like there's a key
under the mat also I ripped the door off
the hinges there's not even a door just
come inside I'm just getting the Beast
but bring the car grandma got knocked
over by a reindeer so close carol of the
bells I don't have a problem with carol
of the bells carol of the bells is a
really excellent way to get elderly
people to sing the word Dom all over
Christmas is my two front teeth
everybody pauses and stares at me these
two teeth are gone as you can see I
don't know just who to blame for this
catastrophe but my own wish on Christmas
Eve is as plain
it can be all up for Christmas and my
two front teeth this is a cry for help
from a child of parents that never
properly explained that your teeth will
grow back also how do you know the word
catastrophe you're for if this child is
this stress out about teeth when it hits
puberty it's it's gonna be bad little
drummer boy little drummer boy is about
a drummer boy meeting baby Jesus and he
says he doesn't have any gifts to bring
other than to play his drum this is like
the 12 year old kid with 12,000 penny
boards around the corner from you that
just got a drum set and it really wants
to play a solo for you unless you're
Dave Grohl one of the worst to word
combos that you can say to me and a
newborn baby on Christmas is drum solo
Rudolph okay I was taking out Rudolph
earlier and Rudolph is essentially the
original version of baby got back oh my
god Becky look at her butt all of the
other reindeer used to laugh and call
him names she looks like one of those
rap guys girlfriends it's just people
chastising someone else for something
that they don't have themselves and then
some slightly overweight dude says he
loves it and everyone's like oh [ __ ] I
need that jingle bell rock jingle bell
jingle bell Jingle Bell Rock it's the
saddest original version of rock paper
scissors last Christmas this song makes
me feel awful
last Christmas I gave you my heart but
the very next day you gave it away and
then later in the song it says
wrapped it up and sent it with a note
saying I love you I meant it now I know
what a fool I've been but if you kiss me
now I know you'd fool me again someone
take this girl to an Applebee's happy
hour fill this girl with appletinis so
she doesn't make the same mistake
perfect in a pear tree which is
otherwise known as the twelve days of
Christmas
this song is essentially about a woman
that finally broke and went crazy
because their significant other got her
this gifts for the twelve days leading
up to Christmas I don't have seven swans
swimming now to get us some pond because
you've got me all these swans now this
is just a song she sings reminding
herself that that actually happened on
the first day of Christmas he gave me a
partridge in a pear tree
all I wanted was the Victoria Secret
gift card but there you go there's my
analysis of holiday songs happy holidays
I don't know where's your toy yeah why
did you leave it there why don't you go
get it nothing I lose my phone a bit
first all the time the tax rejoices in
the background of my dog coos hello
would you like to introduce yourself to
people that don't know who you are or
what you are
this is goose goose is my dog she's been
a doggy daycare while I'm out of town
and that she's back for her cutting up
until your head is bigger than my head
and you are so much tinier than me in
the body this now got weird goose why
your head so big oh I'm sorry
the thirst is real